we're getting a last look at the sari
I'd look at the last known footage of a
missing University of Utah student it
shows McKenzie looook at the airport
shortly before taking a lift to a park
outside Salt Lake City Jonathan
Vigliotti is at the park in North Salt
Lake Jonathan who met her there and
Anthony good morning that's exactly what
police are trying to get to the bottom
of Luke was last seen nine days ago
meeting someone in their car in this
parking lot in the middle of the night
police say they have received about 125
tips but so far they've been unable to
identify that driver or the vehicle
they're now calling on the FBI to help
them solve this puzzling mystery Salt
Lake City police are hoping these
surveillance photos of McKenzie looook
taken less than an hour before she
disappeared will help bring them closer
to finding the 23 year old finding
McKenzie remains a very high priority
for us the photo show looook arriving at
Salt Lake City International Airport
shortly after 2:00 a.m. on Monday June
17th after going home to California for
a funeral she's seen wearing black
sweatpants and a light-colored sweater
while carrying two bags in a brown
suitcase from the airport looook took a
lyft ride at about 2:40 a.m. to hatch
park in North Salt Lake arriving just
before 3:00 in the morning the lyft
driver told detectives
that's where looook was met by an
individual in another vehicle and said
she showed no signs of distress as she
placed her bags in the car and left
police say they've only been able to
gather a vague description of the
unknown driver it could have been a male
or a female we have exhausted all
avenues of determining that information
and want to ask this person to please
call us signs at the park indicate there
are surveillance cameras but it turns
out they aren't actually real instead
acting only as a deterrent for crime and
police have served several search
warrants so they won't say if they
pertain to loic's cell phone records
which Gale that cell phone may have been
turned off Jonathan we are a whole all
hoping this story has a good ending
thank you very much